as you all know there is a global
situation going on that affects the
whole world
and of course people looking for jobs
are affected in a significant way
right now as well most companies around
the globe have moved their recruiting
efforts to online formats
this is also true for consulting where
the case studies behavioral interviews
and other problem solving games now all
take place in the online world and this
of course poses some new challenges to
candidates
in this video i'm going to share how the
recruiting processes of mbb consulting
firms this stands for mckinsey bcg bane
but also other tier 1 tier 2 consulting
firms do look like at the moment
for that i talked to several friends who
had interviews in these firms in the
last months and also did a little
instagram survey where i got lots of
other impressions from people literally
around the world so i'm first going to
describe how these interviews look like
at the moment but them also sharing a
couple of tips and tricks what you can
do to better adapt to the situation and
hopefully improve your performance in
these interviews as much as possible so
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel firm learning my name is
heinrich and on my channel i want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career though
before we start i want to make the
disclaimer that even within the same
firm
interview processes can change
significantly country by country
also offers by office within one country
so as always take this information with
a grain of salt though i do believe that
there are some valuable lessons to be
learned for most people applying to
consulting in these special times so
let's start now though what many people
reported is that most of these
consulting firms now apply a two-tiered
approach they have some kind of
automated assessment going on as a first
step
and then they conduct the more
well-known regular interviews as a
second step
in some type of telephone or video
conference based format so let's jump
into both of these
types one after the other and then let
me share some insights on them as well
so let's start with the automated online
assessment
almost all of these consulting firms
have some kind of digital tests like
this going on it's already pretty well
known as the mckinsey problem solving
game where based on their information
they ask you to balance out
an ecosystem pretty much check how well
you can interact with information
presented in tables and other forms and
a similar but maybe a bit more
traditional approach is what bcg is
doing with their interactive online case
this again is where we will need to
answer different questions but more in a
case-based format
performance which more closely resembles
the case interviews that you are also
known from the main interviews that you
will then face in the second step so
several people ask me
what can i do to prepare for that this
is not even the standard case format
what can i really do there isn't much
material out there and one type of prep
material that i found really helpful for
these types of online assessments is the
gmat integrated
reasoning material so for the
uninitiated integrated reasoning is a
section of the gmat test
gmat is a big standardized
computer-based test that is needed for
almost all mba
programs to get admitted to them and in
this integrated reasoning section you
get
different little problems with graphs
with charts which other information that
is presented to you and then you are
asked to answer multiple choice-based
questions
based on these materials and from
everything that i've seen on her this is
exactly the type of format that is used
by many of these consulting firms so if
you are looking
for some widely available prep formats
check out the integrated reasoning
section of the gmat you will find lots
of books on these topics online so trust
this can be helpful for you
the next point that many people
underestimate is the time pressure that
many of these tests
put you into so often it's not the case
that you have open-ended time but in the
program there is a timer that runs down
and once the time is at zero you will
not be able to answer any more questions
and of course as most of these tests are
multiple choice you should make sure
that you get until the very end because
for instance there are four
answer options available in the multiple
choice then just if you are guessing in
the end you still will be able to get 25
of the points 25 right so really do some
time management so practice this as well
again here the gmat prep material can be
really helpful
because there is where you have these
time-based tests so make sure that at
some point you might just accept to lose
on a question just to move on because
you do want to avoid of spending
all your time on one of many many
questions that you need to answer
and last you're on the online assessment
section always look out for
little traps that they pull out for you
because of course they also want to test
how accurate you can think under
pressure so i've seen how many of these
sets where there are some little
traps included so for instance you might
be required to multiply a number with a
certain percentage figure and then this
percentage figure is stated as
0.03 percent so i'd assume that many
people will just take the number and
multiply it by 0.03 because they believe
that if they do that they are
multiplying it with 3
but of course as the number is stated as
0.03
percent then you need to divide this
number by an additional 100 to actually
be able to multiply it correctly
so again these little things might seem
obvious but if you're under time
pressure looking at these tasks
this will exactly be the things that you
will miss or another thing that i've
seen is that maybe there was one number
given to you
maybe the cost of the business in one
year and then there were lots of
information
given from which you needed to calculate
the cost of that business
in the other year the next year but then
they didn't ask you for the cost of the
next year but they asked
for the difference between the cost of
the first and the second year so pretty
much needed to calculate the cost for
the second year and then subtract the
cost
from the first year and here again i'd
assume that lots of people will just
insert the total cost for the second
year just because they were under
pressure
didn't read this that accurately so
always take the time
to really precisely understand what you
really need to calculate to not make
these little mistakes that then cost you
the points
even though you actually were on the
right track you actually actually had
all the numbers maybe did all the
calculations correct but you just messed
up by just answering precisely
what was being asked from you so these
are these automated online assessments
which now get
more and more popular with these
consulting firms but then at least all
the firms that i
heard of still also conduct interviews
person by person
and these take place via video call most
of the time now i heard of a couple of
instances when the first round there
also was a telephone interview and i
also heard of instances where there were
case interviews conducted on the
telephone so i personally believe that
this is quite crazy because if you
cannot even look somebody in the
eye this is really difficult but this
might happen to you but then at least
for the second round for the more
serious interviews there will be video
calls so most of them would i've heard
of taking place on zoom but i've also
heard of these interviews taking place
on webex on teams
or whatever but here you can trust that
in the company will provide the required
infrastructure for you to be able to
join and then in these interviews
all of these mbb consulting firms
continue to use the two main interview
types which are also used in the part
and this is of course
first the case interview so i will try
to soil the case that the interviewer is
presenting for you and then second the
behavioral part or personal
impact part or personal experience part
or whatever the different names are that
these companies come up for that and
this is the interview we're confronted
with specific
situations that might have happened in
your life we are supposed to tell some
stories how you handle these situations
in the past and then there will evolve a
conversation around that so here the
bottom line is that this interview part
still
is very similar to how things were
before the current situation
evolved so if you want to prepare for
that look up all the information that
you find readily available in the
internet on how to win in case
interviews how to win in behavioral
interviews this will still be very much
applicable though still i want to share
two considerations that are really
special about this online interview
video conference format and the first is
that of course because you're not
sitting face to face in a room
it would be much more difficult to show
the interviewer your notes
because this is a common tactic
especially in case interviews to make a
very visual drawing of your structure of
the case and then show it to the
interviewer and then have a discussion
based on your notes
this of course will be very difficult so
you might try whether you can maybe hold
it in your webcam
based on the quality of your webcam and
also how well the autofocus is
it is very likely that this will not
really work away that you will not be
really
able to show your notes to the
interviewer so what this means is that
you need to be even more deliberate
even more salient even more clear and
transparent
about what your thought process is so
guide the interviewer through your
thoughts really explain him the
structure and to put even more aim for
this on this
than you might need to put in a
face-to-face interview because you do
not have the chance to show the
interviewer the notes anymore and then
the next advice that i have and here
especially if you
have a whole set of interviews lined up
for the next weeks a month really try to
invest into your video conferencing
equipment you would be surprised how
many candidates will sit there just with
an old laptop an old built-in webcam in
the laptop
of not even full hd and then also not
really using a proper microphone or just
the built-in mic that comes with your
laptop so why this might
work and i trust many people will also
be able to get offers with such an
equipment
one way to show your professionalism at
least on a subconscious level for the
interviewer is to make sure that you
really have a good picture that you
really have professional audio
professional sound so here if you
are willing to invest a couple of
hundred bucks
this might be worthwhile if you have a
whole set of interviews now lined up i'd
encourage you to
first upgrade your audio i believe the
audio will be the most important factor
driving your impression and you can get
some very decent usb
mics which are pretty much plug and play
for 100 bucks or below
and then second if you are willing to
invest a little bit more try to get at
least the full
hd webcam and if you have a good and
current dslr
there are different options to also use
your dslr
also mirrorless camera as a webcam and
this of course will significantly
increase your picture quality and then
the third tip to really improve your
picture with simple means is lighting
even bad cameras will always look much
better
if you have good lighting here again for
50 bucks or so you could get yourself a
nice
ring light one that i also have here in
front of me this will put great light on
you and this will significantly improve
the picture output that you have and
again if you do all this the interviewer
will
notice it here's one candidate after
each other all of them with crappy audio
crappy video you know you
suddenly sitting there like a pro this
will make
some kind of impression this will show
that you're serious and that you have a
professional mindset when approaching
these types of situations so hope that
this was helpful and insightful as
always if you have any questions leave
me a comment below in the comment
section i will do my very best to answer
every single comment that you write and
as you know every comment helps me with
the youtube algorithm so it's very much
appreciated to hear from you guys
let me know where i can help and then if
you took any value out of this video at
all please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date on all my content i also have
a mailing list you can sign up to that
via the link in the video description
and if you want to see even more from me
also follow me on instagram my handle is
firm learning and i'd also invite you to
reach out on linkedin again link to my
linkedin below in the video description
let's get in touch i'd love to hear from
you i now want to say thank you to all
the members of firm learning you're
really making a difference
for this channel for the course thank
you so much and if you want to become a
member as well and get access to some
member only perks hit the join button
next to the subscribe button so if you
watched until the end let me know below
in the comments just that i know this is
very much appreciated i'm releasing
videos
every single week on saturdays and
sometimes even some additional bonus
videos so very much looking forward to
talk to you again here in one week until
then good weekend to all of you this is
heineken from learning
bye bye cheers guys